foreign
I was not ready to call that yet it had
to have been a nuclear option for him to
do that like there had to be like he
knew going into that I'm going to blow
up everything and it's worth it because
I can't keep doing this
[Music]
what up what up what up this is John
with the Dr John deloney show
show about your emotional health your
mental health your kids parenting
marriage dating whatever you got going
on in your life we're here to walk
alongside you and help you figure out
what's the next crooked wobbly step
towards
a better future look like and we're here
to walk with you show us about real
people calling with real challenges
going on their lives and um I mean I
know the answer but I promise I'll sit
with you if you want to be on the show
give me a buzz at
1-844-693-3291 it's
1-844-693-3291 or go to John deloney.com
ask a-s-k and don't forget building a
non-exist life is still in Pre pre-sale
we're gonna pre-sell it until January of
2029. so it's going to be pre-sale for
nine years or how what year six years
um but not really it comes out October
3rd we're getting close right Kelly
well yeah it's
end of the end of August so we're
getting there well I know but like when
this episode comes out it'll be getting
really close this episode comes out at
the almost at the end of September okay
so we're really really close
um go pre-order this if you're gonna
pick it up it's 20 bucks and I got a lot
of bribes in there for you to make it
worth your while to pick it up a little
bit early it'll be in your mailbox
October 3rd so go ahead and go for it
um hey I'm gonna call an audible
oh great yeah I have got to say how
freaking proud
I am of John and Ben
y'all we had battle bands Friday night
and I tell you we live in Nashville the
talent is high here I mean multiple
bands that I would pay to see
and
it was the most perfect set ever and
I've been to 11 Battle of the Bands
ever the most perfect set and just my
2000 emo pop punk heart was so happy but
y'all they worked their butts off for
this and I was telling Ben the just pure
unadulterated Joy watching Ben
oh man it's just I threw out my neck
yeah I looked over and thought to myself
he's gonna have a hard time wiping for
the next few weeks but I while I'm
playing it but uh yeah I I watched that
too but how much fun Ben was that it was
just amazing to watch y'all and I know
the work y'all put in and it was amazing
and we had so much fun and we are also
so very proud of y'all I appreciate it
hey having you all down there on the
front row and it was uh like I mean
there's a couple thousand people in
there having you on the front row and I
I will say this there was one moment I
told you I couldn't make eye contact
with you because I was dressed up like
Avril Lavigne
um if she was a six foot two Guy and um
by the way
I've totally blew this and if I wish I
had known I told Ben
if we had had a camera crew with me
and filming my exchange with the woman
working the register at Hot Topic
you were I guarantee you the oldest
person in there trying to explain to her
why I did not want to be in the Hot
Topic rewards program
and that just didn't compute and she was
like can I have your number and I'm like
no I just want to give you money for
that pile and of stuff of wristbands and
like elbow pads or whatever and she was
like I I just needed your number I was
like I'm not gonna give that to you and
it just went downhill from there Chris
said it was pretty amazing to get a text
that said hey I'm in Hot Topic does
anybody need anything yeah you're like I
just spent a hundred dollars okay so
what year is it she goes the lady at Hot
Topic um when I had all the stuff and
she's
your total is going to be 97.64 would
you like to round up in the other
whatever 26 Cents whatever
and I just in shame just dropped my head
I was like yes I just spent 98 dollars
at Hot Topic and did she call you sir
because she was no not used to dealing
with no elderly people in there strange
but but listen I couldn't make eye
contact her but I did look down one time
and you all look like y'all having so
much fun and I knew that if it was not
going well you have a very distinct look
when I'm doing something that's not
going well artistically I've seen it a
number of times but the fact you were
you were y'all are having fun and I
heard Jenna singing her little Taylor
Swift heart out which was awesome that
was amazing I couldn't have asked for
any cover of that song any better yeah
foreign
[Music]
here's the big disaster takeaway for me
I have not practiced like at the
beginning of this thing I picked we
picked a group of songs I wasn't good
enough to play it literally like I had
to sit down and practice and I made a
deal with myself every day no matter
what you will at least pick up your
guitar for 10 seconds every day
and by being that well prepared it
allowed for when the show started to
just go bananas because there was muscle
memory at that point
and I thought man if I worked that hard
on this show it would be so good it
would be incredible if I put that much
work into it so it's it's been
it was I'm glad we did it because now
I'm like I can work pretty hard and get
better results than what I get on this
show that's all thank y'all for coming
it means the world to me yeah the
support means a lot is awesome
and seeing Sarah done in the mosh pit
made my heart really just feel big it
was awesome all right let's go out to
Pennsylvania and talk to Ellie what's up
hi Dr John I'm good how are you
you know what I've got a lot to be
thankful for I'm living blessed living
blessed oh that means something's a
disaster
whenever somebody deflects like I'm
mostly great that's awesome yeah what's
up it sounds better than I'm horrible
right it may be a little less less a
little more disingenuous but yes it does
sound better what's up
so I got a little bit of a question for
you today and I'm just gonna kind of
start with a question and then sort of
fill in the Gap
um
my husband and I are really struggling
with physical intimacy
um I really we're just it's not working
it's not going well we're not connecting
um there's a lot of background to that
um we've been married for 15 years
we have six children our oldest is 13.
the youngest is almost two
um when the baby was four months old I
discovered that he had gone and gotten
of affecting me without my knowledge
um that was
a real game changer for me I was not
ready
to call that yet
um I have loved being a mother
it's sort of been my whole life and so
it just threw me for a tailspin
since then our marriage has just kind of
Tanked to be honest we have just not
been doing well at all feels like we've
sort of hit rock bottom and I feel very
stuck and I'm just wondering if you
could
give me some insight maybe some advice
so that doesn't happen in a vacuum
right I would be stunned if he had not
had conversations about if y'all had not
talked about this is enough this is too
many or when you got pregnant again and
number six and he started struggling or
number five
that's a strange bold move just to do
out of left field with no warning no
conversation
there had been conversations I had
repeatedly said I am not okay with that
particular option I'm not okay with that
um we had explored other options and
even tried some different things and
um yeah number number six was a surprise
um I was not expecting to get pregnant
again
um but
I did know he was getting done and he
did know I wasn't there so it didn't
completely come out of the blue
okay
so
the only way I know how to answer some
of these questions that I know are going
to get me in trouble no matter what I
say is just to give you what's
um was just right at the top of my soul
right now is that okay
yes please so
um
I believe strongly that when people when
couples get married when you say I'm all
in on you and you're all in on me that
we make decisions like this together
I I also
like to flip things around gender wise
and see how does it play on the other
side
I'm trying to imagine a guy calling in
saying I told my wife that she's gonna
and she went and
had a hysterectomy or some sort of
procedure and she hysterectomy as a
whole you can't hide that one but
um went had a procedure done and my
first thought would be hey dude that's
her body
like if she doesn't want to go through
all of that again
and so I'm flipping that around and I
know childbirth is in incredibly
different for a woman's body than a
man's body
but I have to say it had to have been a
nuclear option for him to do that
like there had to be like he knew going
into that I'm going to blow up
everything and it's worth it because I
can't keep doing this
and whenever somebody does that I guess
I just um maybe this is a fault of mine
but I get real empathetic really fast to
think what must have same as if
somebody's like like struggling with
alcohol my first thought isn't I can't
believe you're drinking my first thought
is my God what has happened in your life
that the only way you can get through a
day is like this
and so I have to ask and I'd love to
have I'd love to talk to him I'd love to
ask like dude what was happening in your
life that you knew I might blow up
everything
but I cannot do another kid I can't I'm
out I've lost my wife I've lost my home
I've lost I'm scared of finances
whatever the thing is that just feels
like such a nuclear option so I guess
for both of you my shoulders drop
and my hope would be
that after 15 years and six kids
y'all have been through a lot of ups and
a lot of downs that when somebody pulls
a nuclear option like that that it is
not a
everybody goes running for the hills but
it is a
whoa whoa whoa what just happened here
and it brings you closer together
at least maybe not closer together but
at least brings you to the table
for you to say was I that bad
or was I that unreasonable or maybe I
didn't hear you right
or we have to reimagine our life now
because I imagine it's with eight kids
and you just you just set the nuclear
option right and so right again it's a
major it's a such a violation
and at the same time it's such a
violation that I'd have to say something
else in that in that ecosystem is just a
mess my guess is your marriage has been
struggling for a while is that fair
that's totally fair
So when you say it's just kind of Tanked
and bottomed out what does that mean
do you hate him are you so mad and
enraged that you can't be around him or
is he so ashamed at what he did like
tell me where that where that bottoming
out is is happening
so I think I wouldn't say I hate him
um I I hate what happened I hate what it
has caused
um just hold on but but everything after
that is all the causation is a choice
so yes it happened it didn't make you be
mean to him and it didn't make him hide
in shame and it didn't make you not want
to sleep with him anymore it didn't make
him not want to sleep with you anymore
all those are choices y'all have made on
the back end of this nuclear of him
pulling the pin right
so what are some choices y'all have made
on the back end that have just continued
to spiral this thing out
I I think it's
voices of like well where do we go from
here I feel like I've been betrayed he
feels betrayed I feel like trust is
broken he feels like trust is broken how
do we rebuild this and
um and then it's all about sort of
closing in on each individually like
well I need this well I need this and
you weren't giving it to me and I'm I'm
not getting it now and
is it back and forth and we cannot seem
to get to a place where we can move
forward from here
and I don't know how to
let go
I feel stuck I I don't know how to let
go of the resentment the anger
the hurt
what is anger and resentment getting you
right now
because it's playing it's Play It's
serving a purpose it's playing a role
what's a get getting you right now
oh
maybe in some weird way
it's still
means that
my opinions in place
because I felt like
he completely disregarded how I felt
about this I don't think so I think he
absolutely took into consideration your
opinion
I think what you can't rest wrap your
head around is you didn't get your way
okay and that's a totally different
thing
he can hear you what do I do with that
you tell me
you've got six beautiful kids you have a
family of eight
you had a picture where it's gonna be a
family of 10 or a family of nine that
picture's now gone
so you tell me what comes next
do you simmer in anger and resentment
and despair
or do you sit down with your husband and
say
like
it was so important for me that we have
more and you violated that and you snuck
around me and did it and he says I know
because you wouldn't hear me out
and then you both say will you build
something completely new from the floor
up with me
that's the only way forward there is no
going back there's no going backwards to
this like I don't know maybe you could
get it reversed
so are you just saying lots of feelings
up and no just not go there no I don't
know what to do with the feeling
I'm saying you have
you have changed yourself chained
yourself you have hitched yourself to
your feelings
feelings are very very important but
they often lie to us and they don't tell
us the truth
they're not not feelings are not truth
tellers that's not their job their job
is to get our attention
and so your body may feel like I hate
that guy and that's why challenging
those feelings writing them down and
challenging them do I really hate that
guy no but I'm really really heartbroken
in what he did
and grief demands a witness
I don't think you've grieved this I
think you're at War
and again let me say this if he was on
the phone I would say dude what were you
doing
but he's not on the phone so I can only
talk to you and what you're doing is
you're poisoning your home hoping it
kills him but it's killing you
yeah
and affecting our children and just the
whole environment absolutely is this a a
deep betrayal yes
is it also his body yes is that make
this super messy yes
but it sounds less like he didn't listen
to my opinion it sounds more like I
didn't get my way
and
that turns it into a he won and I lost
and I don't lose not in my house
and I'm just gonna tell you that that
that attitude in a marriage is a recipe
for this thing ends
and you end up with as a single mom with
six kids
yeah I don't want to go there I know you
don't
but also
if you don't want to go there you have
to put in the work to
build something completely new
so before this happened after kid three
or after kid four what was the
challenges in your marriage
finances were a challenge
um
just both of us have strong Wills
and so
conflict was present all the time I tend
to withdrawal in Conflict so nothing
ever got resolved I would just withdraw
when conflict showed up and um
we would never actually get any of our
issues worked out everything got shoved
under the rug
that was just a tip of the iceberg
is there a chance that he was just a
prop in the world that you wanted to
create for yourself
I've never thought of it that way but
maybe often when other people are
playing a part in our picture
of our life
when they don't do what we want them to
do as a part of that picture
we don't we go to war we don't have a
because it's not building something
together it is no it's Christmas is
going to look like this
if you don't do Christmas like this then
I'm gonna withdraw I'm gonna fight you
to the death because Christmas looks
like this in my freaking picture
and that happens over what time we leave
for church it happens over what we have
for dinner and when you're going to be
home and what this looks like and how
our kids are going to be because I could
see on this side of it
um if y'all are up till midnight
stressed about finances
and you want to bring four or five more
kids into this thing I could see that
not computing
and also the rational part doesn't well
but I can also see you wanting four more
kids and he's out buying four-wheelers
and boats and whatever and you're like
well if you weren't buying stupid stuff
then
we can afford this big beautiful family
but it sounds to me like he's a prop
in I will have 10 kids or I will have
eight kids or even more than that I'll
get whatever I want because this is my
life
and his job is to give me what I want
and if he you happen to be a prop in his
life
or if he's just tired of trying to build
something together because there is no
together because it's going to be
elsewhere or no way
or she just withdraws and disappears
see what I'm saying how can I change
that if that's who I am how I don't know
change that I don't you just made that
an identity and I'm not gonna I don't
want you to to do that I don't I'm not
gonna let you get away with that at
least on the phone call
I think you're probably a great mom
and I think you can you have been a
great wife in Seasons especially
I think you are so exhausted
that you don't know what day it is
and I think your body is so desperate
for connection and your way to get to
connection is to control every single
variable on the planet
is that fair
yeah I'm definitely somewhat of a
control freak yeah
I only know that because your husband
went and did something crazy
that's Madness right going to get a
vasectomy without even telling your wife
yeah I I don't even know how that would
be possible
I mean I know how it would be possible
but like even after care and stuff I
just don't understand I can't write my
head around that
But ultimately I think you have to get
to a place where I am going to
let me back up you have to decide my
marriage
to this man
is worth more than me my pseudo fake
pretend control over every variable
you have six kids there's gonna be
variables shooting all over the place
that's six different girlfriends and
boyfriends in six different so I don't
want to date anybody's in six different
struggling in different classes that's
six different car insurances and
colleges six different there's gonna be
variables everywhere
more than I will control I'll shut the
system down and if I don't get control
I'm going to take control in the one
down position I'm just going to withdraw
and go fine if you just want that I'll
just leave then
more so than that you gonna want
connection which means you're gonna have
to choose vulnerability which means you
have to risk getting hurt
and the irony is the more you try to
control the more you are guaranteeing
you get hurt
because at the end of the day people
don't like to be controlled and
eventually they go off and do something
insane
or destructive or they're so desperate
to feel alive or breathe they go do
whatever
so ultimately you have to sit down and
say not who's what who's getting whose
way
but you and your husband have to create
a home that worth living in
create a marriage worth staying in
what does that look like number one I
will refuse to be led around by the nose
by my feelings
I will say my feelings out loud I will
process them I'll have a counselor that
I talk to I'll have a couple of
girlfriends that I'll talk to I will
have a journaling practice that I will I
will commit to the end of time to write
down how I feel and then I will go do
the next right thing whether I feel like
it or not
I don't feel like being nice to him
because he made me what
how can I love you today
I don't feel like picking up the trash
after these dumb kids he's worked 14
hours today I'm gonna go pick up the
trash
I don't feel like exercising or I don't
feel like going to bed I want to watch
the show I will go to bed I'm gonna go
exercise I'm gonna go do what I need to
do
feelings are very important never smush
them down they will come out and they
will destroy everything and they don't
tell the truth that's not their job
their job is just to get your attention
to Signal something in this relationship
isn't okay something in this
relationship is not safe
Strangely I think the way forward is for
one of y'all to go first and since you
called me I'll suggest you if he had
called me I would suggest him
but it's a matter of going out to lunch
or going out to breakfast or going out
to dinner with no kids
and if you say well I can't leave my
kids that's problem number one
but you figure out how to pay for a
babysitter and you get somebody to watch
your kids or a neighbor to come watch
your kids
and you'll go out and you say for the
last 15 years I've tried to control
Every Breath You you take and I'm not
doing that anymore
and for the last 15 years every time I
didn't get my way I've pulled away I've
run from you because that kept me safe
as a kid I'm not doing that anymore and
I'm gonna have to practice I'm gonna
have to learn how when I feel myself
retreating I'm going to stop it turn
around and come back in
because I love you that much
and then here's the kicker
would you promise to work on the things
that make it hard for me to be safe in
this home
because if he says no then what are we
doing
but if you go first
he may join you
and I would love it if you would have
him call me because I'd love to hear his
side of the story
but right now is not the time for
you should get that reversed or we're
now we're gonna have to go adopt now is
the time to stop everything and save
your marriage and you're not saving what
was the building has fallen it has hit
the ground and it is scattered
everywhere
you cannot sweep up all that glass and
steel
and wood and smoke and rebuild that
building you got to build something
completely new
and it starts with one of you saying I'm
all in in these ways will you join me
and that's a scary scary thing to say
hang on the line I'm gonna send you a
copy of building a non-anxious life it
could be a road map for you and your
husband
what if we built a home that we both
liked being in that was loud in chaotic
because we have six kids but it was also
warm and filled with laughter and joy
and a lot of weird
um silly things that we do and romance
and sex again
chose that life
we built something new are you in
thanks for the call I'm so sorry I know
it's a mess on a mess on a mess
[Music]
we'll be right back
hey good folks deloni here with some
great news you get to choose whatever
you do good or bad moving forward the
choice is yours and when you're
intentional about making good choices
over time those become healthy habits
they almost become automatic like
choosing to slow down and make time for
a daily practice of prayer and
meditation one thing that has helped me
with my daily practice is hallow hallo
is the number one Prayer app in the
world and they're giving you three free
months to get started that's three
months for free to prioritize your
mental and spiritual health and be
intentional about finding peace through
calming music through guided prayers
meditation and more and by the way
Hollow isn't just Catholic you can
tailor the content towards your faith
tradition or if you don't have a faith
tradition it's a great place to start
from scripture readings to prayers to
journaling hallow makes it easy to
practice mindfulness build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and choose
peace remember hallow is giving you 90
days free imagine the peaceful habits
you can establish in 90 days go to
hallow.com deloney today to start your
free trial just follow the simple
prompts at hollow.com deloney for 90
days free
all right we're back let's go out to
Roanoke Virginia and talk to the gray
great and wonderful Rachel what's up
Rachel
hey Dr John how are you so good how are
you
I'm good thank you for taking my call
awesome thank you for calling what's up
yes and as as I'm talking to you you
realize that I've been practicing my
questions to you in my head all morning
hey it's practice is good it practice is
good go for it what's up all right okay
so um my husband and I have been married
for 15 years and over the years whenever
I have conflict with anybody from his
side of the family so whether it's
mother-in-law or any of the four
sister-in-laws or anybody from his side
of the family I tend to channel the
frustration or the anger from those
conflicts towards my husband even though
it has nothing to do with him or he has
no involvement in those conflicts I
Channel it towards him and the way I
justify is hey he's part of that family
so he deserves this kind of treatment
from me and I know it's totally crazy
totally unfair so my question to you is
how do I Channel my frustration away
from p people I love and I guess even
more importantly how do I get it out of
my system is my question if that makes
sense yeah I think that you're operating
on a bad model
um
foreign
I'm not saying this in a derogatory way
this is like I'm trying to say this
clinically that's a very child based
response
I'm mad about this over here so I'm
gonna spit on you all right this thing
happened to me from this guy I'm gonna
kick you
right or you see kids they stub their
toe at a door and then they punch a
chair right like I'm gonna go get that
thing
that's a very childish response it comes
from an eight so
um the bad model is that the get it out
model is been proven faulty it's not
real
there was a whole there was decades
where they would tell you to quote
unquote get your anger out it's a thing
you have to get out you have to and you
they have these they even have them now
they got smash rooms and yell rooms and
I have to tell you what you did I gotta
say all these things I have to get this
out of my body
um what the research tells us is what it
does is it actually reinforces those
neural Pathways and makes them stronger
it makes the the the connections more
reinforced
so every time you take your anger on
your husband your body reinforces that
is the appropriate way of getting of
making yourself feel better which is to
hit somebody else to spit on somebody
else
and the only way to break that there's
not a way to getting it out the only way
to break that is to grieve it which I
don't think you've ever done
and
um decide I'm not going to act this way
and eventually over time you teach your
body different levels different ways to
deal with that stress whether it's going
for a walk whether that is writing in a
journal whether that's playing your
guitar whether that's any going dancing
any number of things
but you have to make the choice I'm
going to stop hitting my husband for
other things people are doing I'm gonna
stop spitting in his face for something
his father did
now anytime somebody excuse me this I
always have to ask
has he done the work of drawing firm
boundaries with his family
he has yes okay we have together we have
over the years yeah and they continue to
violate those boundaries
it's not all the time
if you've done it all what you actually
have to do is to cut off contact
because they are opting out of
relationship with you and what you
really want is you want both and
you want to tell them what your
boundaries are and have them honor them
and they are not
and that makes them not real boundaries
that makes you all just annoying
Chihuahuas just barking a lot
yeah that's what it sounds like usually
yeah instead of saying okay
we've been very clear we won't talk
about X we've been very clear we don't
like it when you use that language we've
been very clear we can't travel on Days
A B and C because of whatever
um
and y'all have opted out of relationship
with us it breaks our heart we're really
sad about that
and I hate going that route because then
it's kind of you're losing your family
right your family left you they left you
Rachel
you're just continuing to let them drag
you behind down behind the truck down
the street
and you're getting mad at them about the
road rash but the whole time you're
hanging onto the Rope
yeah
that's where I say you have to grieve
this whole thing often that that feeling
that I have to get this out that's often
not anger that's grief
foreign it wasn't supposed to be like
this I was supposed to get married and I
was going to be best friends with his
mom and me and his dad he was going to
treat me like his another daughter and
we were going to tell inappropriate
jokes and laugh and have inside jokes
and none of that happened
very true you have to spend some time
being really freaking heartbroken about
that and you haven't and when you're not
when you skip over grief when you skip
over heartbreak it comes out as rage
and you just start hitting the person
closest to you which happens to be the
man you love right
right
so you have to decide to spend some time
in grief and that is not fun
but also hurting your husband over
something he's not doing isn't fun
either
and grief has a weird way of clarifying
your next step
as David Kessler says you end up finding
meaning here's my next PATH it's how
after
um a young high school kid gets killed
by a drunk driver and after three or
four years his mom ends up
starting a non-profit or his mom ends up
going to speak at local high schools or
his dad becomes goes back to law school
to whatever
you find your body directs you you find
meaning there
and that might be where you're like you
know what for me and my house we're
going to choose joy and laughter we're
not going to choose to go back into this
so we're going to find other wise adults
that honor our boundaries and that we
love and that love us and that's what
we're going to spend most of our time
because sadly for us our families are
opting out of relationship with us or
after grieving
then it's like you know what we can just
go to these things and roll our eyes I
don't really care if you're talking
about politics or whatever give me an
example of a thing they do that just
makes you enraged
um sometimes so when we see them
sometimes they would comment on my kids
you know being either you know they're
too skinny for what they think they
should weigh type thing they would want
to opine on my personal life uh things
like that
why do you care what they think
why do you give them access to your your
inner core being like that
that's where I struggle is I don't know
how to block that out of my pocket it's
uh it's not a blocking it's just like uh
I guess maybe it's a blocking
I'm trying to think of a mental model
for that it's not like your Teflon those
things like come into you like they just
don't register the same
it's like when they say it it just gets
stuck with me that every time I see them
those conversations rerun in my head and
then I get all that built up emotionally
are they saying it because they don't
like you and they're being mean or are
they saying it because they genuinely
care about those kids and think they
need to no I think fatten them up I mean
I think yeah I think over the years they
always had a hard time
accepting me as part of the family there
you go
it's not fine it is not fine because you
are
that is Rippling through
your relationship with them
they've never liked you and they're
never gonna like your kids they're not
gonna like how your kids look they
didn't like how you looked they had a
different picture of another woman in in
mind for their son and he picked you
and
they had another picture of what their
grandkids were going to look like not
the ones they got not those skinny
little things and so they're gonna they
have opted out
see what I'm saying
yeah
and what you and your husband have to do
is really grieve that because that's not
supposed to be like that
that's supposed to be like that
yeah
and it breaks my heart because it hurts
my husband yes and the last thing I want
to do is hurt him it's not you're not
his parents are and I know but it's
because of me right nope he chose you
he loves you to the moon and back he
loves you to the end of time
it's because his parents act like
children
and his parents don't actually fully
love their son
his parents loved the role their son
played in making their life perfect
you're right about that are they true
about that they've been doing that to
him his entire freaking life
yep
so what y'all have done is you all
verbalized a lot of boundaries but you
haven't lived them out
in a perfect world your husband sits
down with your parents and says for 15
years you have not accepted or loved my
wife
and for 15 years you've made little
quips and comments and pokes and prods
and now those pokes and prods are
rubbing off on my kids
and I let my wife down because I let it
go on for years without saying anything
or saying hey we don't like that but not
really do anything about it
and now that I'm seeing it with my kids
I realized I was wrong to not get more
vocal with my wife and especially I'm
gonna draw around with my kids
if y'all say these things again and
don't fully accept my wife don't fully
accept my kids don't fully accept our
family
you are choosing for us to not come here
and we will get that message loud and
clear
that's what he should say and that is
not a conversation for you to have
that's a conversation for him to have
right
but until he decides to stop being a
action figure
and his mom and dad's little Playhouse
they're going to continue to try to
exert control over every aspect of his
life
even the appearance of his kids
and we have made it clear over and over
and you know when they make comments I
know but you keep going you keep showing
up you keep showing up you keep showing
up and that's not that's not
your parents have learned oh they're
just gonna they're gonna they're all
bark no bite
they're all they're all barks they're
not gonna actually leave
so we can do whatever we want
we're gonna continue to push and poke
and poke and push and push and poke
until one of the grandkids says
something back
or one day Rachel says something back
and then it's going to confirm it see
told you she's a fill in the blank
told you she's just like everyone else
who fill in the blank
don't give them that
now I also want to be careful because
there's a whole ecosystem now it's like
you just if they don't if they don't
whatever your boundaries you just
abandon them and run away not
necessarily this is 15 years
15 years and my gut tells me there's a
racial component to this there's all
kinds of other layers to this
that
um kind of oog me out grosses me out
pisses me off
and especially when it rolls off of our
son supposed to make us happy and he
didn't follow our directions
and um so now we're going to throw
grenades at his kids no way no way
no way
the job you have to do Rachel is grieve
this number one
because it should be different
your in-laws should be so excited that
the sun they raised
this man that they raised
with good judgment and character and
kindness pick you
and they should be so even if you look
different you appear different you are
whatever it should be so excited that
he's head over heels in love with her
and it looks different but it's painting
time because we're painting a new
picture because this is our new life
we're gonna get to know her and learn
about her
and then when those kids come along oh
my gosh you are big and huge and
muscular when you were a kid and your
kids were skinny little
it's that's a totally different
conversation then you know what they
should be what are you feeding man
you're gonna spend some time in grief
and you are gonna have to open your
hands up and realize that you can't
control the world and you're trying to
control how your husband feels how your
in-laws feel you can't
they're grown adults
but you do have to also decide I'm gonna
stop spitting on my husband because his
parents are children
I'm gonna stop punching my husband
metaphorically
because his parents hurt my feelings
but you also have to sit down with your
husband and say we have to end this we
have to we have to create some space
here because it's hurting our marriage
it's hurting our relationship with our
kids and we can't let outside influences
do that
behavior is a language
and it sounds like your in-laws are
telling you we don't want you or those
kids around
and if your husband has any integrity at
all he says cool
Bye Felicia we gone he leaves
hopefully sits down with him and has a
final direct conversation
but you're not the crazy one Rachel
spend some time in grief
and sometime in heartache
write him a letter don't ever ever send
it write him a letter about what you
really feel
how heartbroken you are
that's step one
then get a couple of friends and read it
to him that's step two we'll be right
back
this episode is sponsored by betterhelp
hey this is deloni I hope you all are
doing well listen sometimes it's hard to
get our brains to turn off and I know
what I'm talking about I am the king of
racing thoughts they've kept me up at
night they've got me up early and kept
me from connecting with people I love if
you find your thoughts start to race
right before bed or during other super
inconvenient times a great way to make
those racing thoughts slow down or stop
is to talk them through and therapy gave
me a place to do that so I could get off
the negative thought treadmill learn
positive coping skills set healthy
boundaries and find some mental and
emotional peace and it can help you too
if you're thinking of starting therapy
give better help a try better help is
convenient because it's entirely online
so it's flexible and can fit into your
schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with the
license therapist and you can even
switch therapists at any time for no
extra charge so take a break from racing
thoughts with better help visit
betterhelp.com deloney today to get 10
off your first month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash deloni
all right we're back let's go to Drake
in Indianapolis what's up Drake
hey Dr John how are you today partying
man what are you up to oh not much just
on my lunch break out here talking to
you my first time my first time on a
podcast so I apologize if I'm not very
good at it well I've been on a lot of
podcasts and I'm terrible at it so same
team I promise you're gonna do great uh
what's up man
we'll make it through uh so call today
first off I'll start off you know the
conversation by saying that my family
and my friends mean the absolute world
of me and I'm I'm pretty blessed to be
surrounded by people that love me but
I've noticed recently I've become hyper
competitive
um with with my friends and sort of the
way that like I I've never really felt
like I stack up or that that I'm
um as good as or that I'm less than so
to speak and so really calling today to
get some direction as to you know how to
change that and and just be kind of at
peace with
um you know other people's success and
you know my stage of life and and so
forth so yeah
um great question man and I appreciate
you calling this I think the
conversation is going to help a lot of
people so I appreciate your bravery
there
um you cannot be at peace with other
people until you're at peace with you
and innately
whatever is going on in your stage of
Life whatever you wish to be different
that's where the that's where the echo
is not in your friends and
um
what have you not grieved anytime
somebody says they're struggling with
comparison
um whether it's somebody's got another
job or a nicer car or a wife or a
prettier wife or a prettier handsome or
husband or whatever the thing is
it almost always comes back to
grief of a life not yet lived
and because I skip over the grief part
the Heartbreak part just sitting in it
for a season I wish this was different
and it's not
and possibly taking inventory of some of
the things that we are participating in
that's making it that way or dealing
with the reality that there's nothing
we're doing it's just not happened
until we do that the only outsources
rage and anger and blame
which by the way is our entire culture
because we have an entire culture who
has outsourced all reality to politics
and media
and so they are we're literally unable
to sit at home and say I wish my life
was different
yeah um in terms of what what your
original question was what what have I
not grieved
um I don't I don't know exactly and it
kind of sounds ridiculous to say out
loud but I'll say it anyway
nothing's ridiculous don't do that to
yourself or don't do that to my buddy
Drake
that's you talking Gus you talking crap
about yourself again I can do that on
the show I do enough of that for me
right you don't do that
um okay whatever your feelings is what
you're feeling dude just own it
no I
I you know all everybody's starting to
get to the stage of life I'm 28 I'm
single right and so everybody's kind of
at that stage of life where they're
they're getting married they're having
kids they're they're they're starting
that stage of their life and there's
really nothing more in the world I want
than that
um and it just for one reason or another
um hasn't happened yet do you have no
you're still young I'm 28. do you have
streaming services
do I have streaming services
yeah
do you um take
ballroom dance lessons
no I do not do you take jiu jitsu
no I do not are you in a running club
uh I do CrossFit that's kind of my my
outlet so you're an occult okay so do
you do um uh any sort of regular
religious services
yeah
I do a Bible study uh most weeks I
haven't in recent weeks because I've
gone back to grad school and time has
just been a little short but but
generally speaking Yeah so what I'm
getting at is I don't think it's the
most important thing in your life that I
don't think it's the thing you want more
than anything else in the world
and that's okay
it sounds like what you want is you want
to have the life that you want and this
other stuff
and for some people that other stuff
literally falls out of the sky
a friend of mine said this is my sister
I think y'all are gonna get married I
can't be your friend anymore because I
can't be friends with a guy who's dating
my sister
and then we got married and now me and
him are great friends
that fell out of the Moon
is that fair no not at all
be so annoyed if I wasn't me
and
that doesn't impact you so the question
is not like
[Music]
um
the question is not why not me the
question is I've got a pretty good life
that I've chosen
and if I want to choose something else
maybe I have to make some different
choices because so far hasn't fallen out
of the sky for me
is that fair
that's fair yeah um and I I think too
I've in recent years really started to
make some some drastic changes and like
what um
well I started working out I mean I I
was way overweight and now I'm not I'm
I'm slightly overweight now so I'll call
that progress
um and I uh Drake
stop with that
if you were way overweight in your less
overweight now that's not I'm just gonna
call that progress
that's one of the single hardest
transitions a human can make in the 21st
century it's amazing
it's incredible
and someone would be so blessed to be
sitting at a table with you with
somebody with your character and
discipline and willpower and joy
yeah
yeah I know I mean you're absolutely
right why don't you like Drake what is
so sucky about Drake
is that you were overweight what is it
no I just you don't like you man why
I I I don't know because I usually have
a pretty good radar and like instantly
you sound like somebody I'd like to hang
out with
and I'm not just saying that you know
I'm not just gonna make that up on the
show like
you sound like a funny guy a good fun
self-deprecating in grad school like
it's like a guy that I would hang out
with literally
why don't you want to hang out with you
I don't know I I just I've always just
seen sort of the negative and what is my
fault tell me what the negative is
because I I bet this I don't believe you
tell me what the negative is change my
mind
um
well I I
don't know
my mind's gone blank no you've got like
two or three things if you could snap
your fingers and make Drake different
right now what would it be
I wish that I was in better shape okay
uh wish I looked better okay
um what does that mean like
aesthetically
yes okay
um
wish I was more confident
okay
um how do we get confidence
uh well where I've had success in that
area is I I go out and I I accomplish
things there you go I look back I'm like
wow I can't believe I did that that's
the only way you get confidence is a
whole bunch of little wins piled up
yeah
you can't you can't uh manifest or
whatever they're saying on the internets
these days you can't invent and just
stayed out into the universe I'm
confident it's not like Michael Scott
like I declare bankruptcy that's not how
that works right you can't do that with
confidence yeah you got to go out and do
okay so you wish you were confident you
wish you weighed less what else you wish
you had more muscle tone or whatever
what else
I I don't
those are the two big ones uh what's in
the black hole
because those sit on there I wish I
those sit on top or something else
I've never thought of myself as very
smart so I wish I was I was smarter
um
that's that that's probably one
um who in your life
who in your life has told you
that you are the sum total of all these
extrinsic things
was it your mom
you got to get this many grades
you got to get into this school is it
your dad where did that come from no
coach I I don't
no I think I I think you know my parents
there was a lot of tension in the house
growing up right so
um
you know it was it was really uh
difficult to be at peace so to speak but
I wouldn't say that they ever told me
that that I'm the the the sum total of
that I mean they're always supportive of
me they just hated each other so they
were always yelling but so hey hold on
so just just so you know and if you've
ever listened to show you've probably
heard me talk about this
kids absorb tension in their home
and it's a biological protective measure
but they make that tension their fault
and they try to solve it
that sounds right and many kids will
spend their entire adult lives trying to
solve that childhood tension
and they always if they can't reconcile
it if Mom and Dad never came back around
and solved their marriage issues and
created a warm safe place for a kid to
land
their nervous system knows one Avenue
you're not enough you couldn't get the
job done
and that you're not enough you couldn't
get the job done is that confidence I
know one thing about me I couldn't get
the job done
and that road rat I mean that's the road
you take into jobs into romantic
relationships into friendships into
church groups into bowling leagues into
dance classes that becomes the path
until you decide I'm taking a machete
I'm gonna head off into the woods I'm
going to create a new one because this
path is going to kill me
yeah
and so as I hear you talk I need you to
hear me say this the one the one thing
about this show I promise I'm gonna tell
the truth
you sound like a guy who's a lot of fun
and you sound like a guy who laughs are
you a guy who laughs
oh yeah I can hear it in you number
three you're in grad school what are you
studying
accounting you're not a good God you're
not dumb you train yourself into a human
calculator for God's sakes although
accounting is just like in that kind of
balance sheet like make sure this side's
got more money in this side anyway
yeah you're you're getting a master's
accountant accountancy is that as they
say
you're not dumb
so here's your path forward okay I'm
gonna give you a couple of things number
one I'm gonna hook you up with my
friends at mind pump and give you access
to any of the workouts that you want on
their whole site for free okay
thank you and you can print it off and
just follow it that's it
at least make a commitment to Drake that
I can do this and you go through there
and pick any ones you want and Jenna
will hook you up with the um those are
some great friends that's the same
workout programs that I use okay so it's
not about mechanics it's about I'm where
I'm worth doing that today I'm worth 45
minutes today I'm worth that okay the
second one is
um
I'm gonna hook you up with my buddy Lane
Norton's uh carbon app okay it's a free
it's I'm gonna give you a lifetime free
subscription to it and all it is is just
about tracking try tracking calories
okay tracking what I eat
yeah it sucks it sucks tracking stuff
because you can't lie to the to the
calculator but it's also amazing okay
and he's gonna give you that for free
the third thing is
I want you to write a letter the
nine-year-old Drake
and when you write that letter I want
you to sit somewhere quietly by yourself
and I want you to become nine-year-old
Drake again I want you to think of the
house tension the volume in the house or
the silence in the house
that feeling of your dad walking into
the room and your mom's storming out
there I want you to feel all of that
and then as 28 year old Drake I want you
to write nine-year-old Drake a letter
and I want you to tell Drake
I'm so sorry
that you tried to carry the stability of
that home
Mom and Dad weren't mad at you
they were dealing with things in their
life that we will that you'll never know
about
but but you're worth being loved and
you're worth having fun and worth having
joy and worth having people like you and
look you in the eye
and then as you said earlier about
confidence
I want 28 year old Drake
to give 28 year old Drake 30 days
and since you mentioned you know working
out we pick that one
but it could have been grad school it
could have been learning a new language
it could have been whatever but will you
give yourself 30 days
and by the way you'll screw up one of
those days I sat with a guy recently um
we're working on it on a I guess for
lack of better terms a TV show and it
was a 90-day Challenge and I checked
with him every 30 days and after the
first meeting I told the team there's no
chance he doesn't make 30 days no chance
he made all 90.
and as we said we shot the final episode
last week uh or two weeks ago and he
said 90 days everything's different the
whole thing the whole machine is turned
around
what I'm going to tell you is if you
find somebody that's wonderful and
beautiful and that you are instantly
want to create a connection with and
make a life with
that Drake that you don't like will show
up
and that's not fair to you and that's
not fair to whoever this person is you
want to meet
and so the work is less to be done on
I've got to go Gotta Go Gotta Get gotta
get I hate it that you got it I can't
believe you have you got you're getting
oh even Steve's getting married Steve
sucks he's getting married
right
yeah it's not that it's dude it's so rad
good for you man I don't understand how
you could get married but it's so so
great that there's a glitch in The
Matrix that way that's awesome
that comes from a place of
I'm okay with me
um I had last year own your past change
your future the book sold a bajillion
copies way more than any of us thought I
was gonna sell
and I grew up a real poor kid and
um my wife didn't have a lot growing up
either I don't say I wasn't a poor kid
we didn't have a lot we did it very very
little
and I've had the same group of buddies
and all of them have done really really
well and as I was I've I've obviously
done good with my higher ed career and
my dean of students jobs and stuff we've
done well but it got silly last year was
a silly year for us
and I called my buddy I said I just need
to tell one person
this is what happened last year
the only person I told an actual number
yeah and he said good God you
and I said I know
and he got quiet
and he said I'm so proud of you I would
start crying if you wouldn't make fun of
me
yeah I had somebody in my corner that
was there for me when things were hard
and he's the guy that I called one time
when I had what I thought was internal
bleeding and I had called him and said
can I borrow your Southwest credit card
so that I can go to the ER and he said I
got you
and he's also the guy that 25 years
later I called and he was like dude I'm
so proud of you
and I want you to start that with Drake
being proud of Drake
look what we're doing man
I'm gonna give myself 30 days I'm gonna
call two buddies I'm just gonna hang out
and we're going to start building
confidence with a bunch of little wins
the other thing I want you to do is I
want you to start keeping a journal of
the negative self-talk the bull crap
stories you tell yourself
I used to be really overweight and I'm
less of a way to guess I'll call that a
win no
that's a true that's that is a win it's
a huge a huge win
be with me she's gonna think uh how do
you know how do you know I don't really
know cool but then we're done with that
thought
until she says I would love you but you
just are too filmably
then we're gonna be sad and grieve that
thought but I'm not gonna I'm not gonna
as Renee Brown says I'm not gonna dress
rehearse tragedy I'm not going to
continue to put all these layers in
front of me and laughter and me and joy
and me and home and me in the future
I'm not gonna do that
to wasting my time
it feels protective but it's not
it's isolating
so I just do a lot at you what do you
think
I think I think you're right man and and
you know like I like I started the call
with with you know how blessed I really
am I I do I'm very fortunate I do have
those friends in my life that that are
you know there but uh have you have you
said talk to him and been honest
yeah
I don't like I have I don't like Drake
yeah okay I have and
um do they call you out for the bull
crap that is
yeah good no they're they're good
they're good at calling that out yeah
good now everybody needs to take one
step more and say okay we've thought
about this a lot we've talked about this
a lot let's start acting one of the
great curses of modern mental health the
idea of quote-unquote mental health is
if you just get all the right thoughts
in the right order then you're going to
be mentally well and I think that's
false that's a false narrative you have
to go do you have to act you have to you
have to engage
and you have to like you said create
confidence based on I kept showing up
for me
I did an exercise thing for 30 days
without stopping
confidence I can
I tracked what I put in my body for 30
days I can
I took a journal and I wrote down every
time I had a negative thought about me
for 30 days and I challenged those
thoughts some of them are true
do I need to have weight to lose yep
that's still true
am I a complete loser nobody will love
me and I'll never have a romantic
relationship because of that no
not true
and on and on and on but all of this
starts with you looking in the mirror
and saying Drake's worth loving Drake's
worth exercising Drake's worth taking
care of our body Drake is worth
calling his buddies Drake is worth
asking her out even if she's gonna say
no
whatever that may be
thank you for the call my brother hey
I'll walk with you every step of the way
you call if you need something if you
get 30 days down the road and you want
to call back and I'll celebrate with you
awesome you want to call back and say
I've completely failed I'm gonna go
again I'll cheer you on again
I'm super proud of you brother and I
think this is going to be the day that
everything changes
cheer for your friends man cheer for
your friends
and cheer for Drake we'll be right back
hey Dr John deloney here I'm super
jazzed to announce my new book building
a non-anxious life is now available for
pre-order listen we all experience some
level of anxiety or stress or burnout
every day but most of us don't know how
to recognize it let alone deal with it
and here's the good news anxiety doesn't
have the last word I know this because
I've sat with thousands of you and I
know this because I've been there too if
you create a life of intentionally
living out the six daily choices I've
outlined in this book you'll be able to
better respond at whatever life throws
at you this book will help you learn
practical steps to overcome anxiety plus
when you pre-order the book now I'm
gonna give you something to help you
today that's why you'll instantly get my
newest talk smoke fire and freedom where
I break down the misunderstandings and
myths we believe about anxiety how to
reclaim your freedom and how to build a
non-anxious life so pre-order building a
non-anxious life today for just 20 bucks
at John deloney.com
all right as we wrap up today's show the
song is by marshmallow and Bastille
marshmallow and Bastille
songs called happier
it goes like this lately I've been I've
been thinking I want you to be happier
when the morning comes when we see what
we've become in the cold light of day
where a flame in the wind not the fire
that we've begun every argument every
word we can't take back because with all
that has happened I think we both know
the way that the story ends then only
for a minute I want to change my mind
because this just don't feel right to me
I want to raise your spirits I want to
see you smile but no that means I'll
have to leave
hmm
I want you to be happier
but sometimes you don't have to leave
either way we're here for you party on
stay in school be excellent to each
other
watch Bill and Ted's bye
[Music]